there is this negative Force out there
that I call resistance with a capital r
a voice in our head that tells us
you're no good you can't do this who are
you to think of whatever project that
you have in your mind and also to
distract you let's go to the beach so
let's have another drink let's have an
affair
if you decide you want to be in the
creative arts it's a war and you're
going to have to fight this Dragon every
morning that you wake up to do that you
have to find some kind of a mindset
whatever it is you know a warrior
mindset the mindset of a mother that's
going to protect you know the life
growing within her whatever it is to
overcome that thing called resistance
that it is a war and you have to fight
it every day